let's go to the phones 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
we are going to try our caller from the
4:08 area code caller from 4:08 go ahead
hey David I want to ask you about the
whole March for Life thing in the whole
gun control debate what do you think on
that I'm sorry which live thing March
for our lives the one those school kids
went on that was across the country oh
yeah yeah no I'm sorry I just I just
misunderstood you well I mean listen I
think that it's absolutely fantastic
that we're seeing a level of engagement
around the gun safety issue that we've
not seen for a while we should have seen
it long ago
my only concern is is it really going to
achieve any change and I don't know the
answer to that well I'm saying that
these kids are sort of like misguided in
a way because I don't think the guns are
the only problem I think we as a country
should focus more on mental health
situation hmm well listen I've said
before that I believe pretending that
the guns aren't a problem at all is not
a good idea
pretending that mental health hold on us
are pretending that mental health isn't
an issue at all is also not a good idea
so as I've laid out before and I'm
curious whether you agree with me I
think that this is a multi-faceted
problem that it's a different problem in
every country so there are other
countries that because of their culture
they don't have as many problems with
guns despite high levels of gun
ownership in the United States we've got
a real problem with it and part of it
comes from a culture that is gonna be
stand sees guns as a way to solve
problems and that's a cultural issue
that's got to be dealt with
well not saying guns aren't the problem
of course guns are the problem but I'm
saying that if we look at you know the
chemistry on why they do it and we look
at the you know the brains of these
people and see what they're thinking we
should be focused more on helping these
people rather than there have to resort
to extremities to make a point but what
do you so give me an example of what you
mean by that what what have we found out
about the group the brain chemistry of
shooters well we know that Nicholas Cruz
was isolated it was pushed over the edge
because of his mother's death because of
him having it go through adoptions and
stuff and I'm sure no one wanted to
listen to him and he felt isolated sure
but what that sounds cultural more
in a brain chemistry issue right but it
also has to start with the problems that
you have in your head that makes you
think this way that makes you think me
going out and shooting people rights
justify it somehow I completely agree
with you I don't I don't agree with you
that we can call it a brain chemistry
issue but you're getting at the point
which is too many people in the United
States believe that taking a gun and
going and shooting people is a is a way
to solve a problem and of course when
they have really easy access to a ton of
guns that makes it possible for them to
wreak a lot more havoc so I think
generally you and I agree well I also
recommended I think we should focus more
on helping like setting up clinics to
help people you know with therapy so
that we can teach and hey you know
there's more ways to get help other than
shooting people and then when we finally
have that problem under control we will
go ahead and go with gun control well I
think there's no reason to delay the gun
control just because you're trying to
work on the mental health resources I
think you do both they both be funded
disparately
and I don't know that you need to wait
on one to do the other but I do
appreciate the call and I think you're
making a lot of very very good points
thank you so much